♪ ♪
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI IS
RAISING ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS
AFTER HIS LATEST MEDIA BLITZ.
THE FORMER MAYOR, NOW SAYING
THAT THE PRESIDENT MAY NOT
COMPLY WITH A SPECIAL COUNSEL
SUBPOENA.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE CAN ASSERT THE SAME
PRIVILEGES OTHER PRESIDENTS
HAVE.
PRESIDENT CLINTON NEGOTIATED A
DEAL WHEN HE DIDN'T NEGOTIATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS --
>> Juan: LAYER GIULIANI IS
UNSURE IF THE PRESIDENT WILL
PLEAD THE FIFTH.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT THE
PRESIDENT WILL NOT TAKE THE
FIFTH IN THIS CASE?
>> HOW CAN I BE CONFIDENT OF
THAT?
WHAT I -- WHEN I AM FACING A
SITUATION WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
ALL THE OTHER LAWYERS ARE.
THEY THINK HE WOULD BE A FOOL TO
TESTIFY.
I HAVE A CLIENT WHO WANTS TO
>> Juan: MR. TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
NOT RULING OUT IF MICHAEL COHEN
MADE PAYMENTS TO OTHER WOMEN ON
BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> IF IT WAS NECESSARY, YES.
HE MADE PAYMENTS FOR THE
PRESIDENT OR HE CONDUCTED
BUSINESS FOR THE PRESIDENT WHICH
MEANS HE HAD LEGAL FEES, MONIES
LAID OUT, AND EXPENDITURES.
WHICH I HAVE ON MY BILLS.
TO MY CLIENTS.
>> Juan: IS RUDY GIULIANI
HELPING OR HURTING HIS CLIENT,
THE PRESIDENT?
I WILL ASK YOU TO START US OFF.
>> Brian: I THINK THE TONE HE
IS SETTING IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS.
HE'S AGGRESSIVE.
ENOUGH SITTING ON MY HANDS.
YOU WANT A MILLION PIECES OF
PAPER?
YOU CAN HAVE IT.
I HOPE YOU DON'T CALL ME FOR A
MEETING.
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING MY FRIENDS.
YOU ARE HASSLING MY FAMILY.
IT'S OKAY.
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
WHAT RUDY GIULIANI HAS TO DO IS
INFORM PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT HE'S
DOING.
EVEN IF HE HAS THE BEST OR WORST
PLAN, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO KNOW.
THE COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WHAT -- BUT
HE WAS DOING AND THE REST OF THE
TEAM DIDN'T KNOW.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
RUDY GIULIANI KNEW WHAT THEY
WERE DOING.
I DON'T THE KEY WAS THAT
SURPRISED.
I TALKED TO DAN FOR A HALF-HOUR
ON RADIO, HALF AN HOUR ON
"FOX & FRIENDS," 20 MINUTES ON
THE PHONE THE DAY BEFORE.
THERE WAS NO PANIC, KNOW WHAT
HAVE I DONE HERE.
HE FELT AS IF HE WAS ON PATH.
WHAT HE HAS TO DO IS COME BACK
AND SAY WE HAVE TO SPEAK WITH
ONE VOICE.
IN ONE WAY, I THINK HE HAD SET
THE TONE WHICH WAS POSITIVE AND
IN ANOTHER WAY, HE SET THEM BACK
ON THE STORMY DANIELS SITUATION.
>> Juan: DANA, I THINK YOU
WERE STRUCK BY THE THINGS THAT
BRIAN JUST HAD.
FOLKS AT THE WHITE HOUSE WERE
LIKE, WE DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS
COMING.
ALL KINDS OF SHOCK AT THIS.
IN ADDITION TO WHICH THE
SUGGESTION THERE MAY BE MORE
PAYMENTS CAME AS AN ABSOLUTE
UNSETTLING FACTOR.
>> Dana: THERE IS A SCHOOL OF
THOUGHT AMONG SOME PEOPLE THAT
IT'S BETTER FOR THE PRESS
SECRETARY ARE PEOPLE DOING
COMMUNICATIONS, FOR THEM NOT TO
KNOW CERTAIN THINGS BECAUSE IT
PROTECTS THEM FROM SOMETHING.
I'VE NEVER SUBSCRIBED TO THAT
THEORY BUT I KNOW IT EXISTS.
IT WILL TURN OUT HOWEVER IT
TURNS OUT.
THE ONLY THING I AM FOCUSED ON
IS SOMETHING THAT I ASKED THE
LEGAL SCHOLAR AT BERKELEY.
VERY ACCOMPLISHED LAWYER.
HE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND HOW
THEY HAVE TO INTERACT.
I SAID WHAT IS THE SETTLED LAW
OF WHETHER A PRESIDENT CAN
IGNORE A SUBPOENA FROM THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH.
HE SAID IT'S THE ONE THING
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DECIDED BY A
SUPREME COURT.
COULD BE THE FIRST TIME IT'S
DECIDED.
>> Juan: THE COURT SAID YOU
HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE DOCUMENTS.
THE QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
TESTIMONY.
BY THE WAY, KIMBERLY, YOU HEAR
THE PRESIDENT SAY RUDY IS NEW TO
THIS.
HE WILL GET HIS FACTS STRAIGHT.
WELL, IS RUDY ON THE PAGE OR
NOT?
>> Kimberly: RUDY IS ON THE
PAGE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE.
THEY ARE VERY CLOSE.
HE RELIES ON HIS COUNSEL.
HE'S COME ONTO THE CASE QUICKLY.
HE IS CATCHING UP, GETTING A
BEAT ON EVERYTHING.
HE'S GOING THROUGH IT.
PROTECT THE PRESIDENT, PROTECT
THE FAMILY.
HE'S TRYING TO BE FORTHRIGHT AND
TRANSPARENT MEANS THE QUESTIONS.
NOT RULING ANYTHING OUT OR IN.
A SMART LAWYER DOESN'T CLOSE
DOORS.
EVALUATE IT.
CASE-BY-CASE DETERMINATION AND
BASES HERE.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE TO TESTIFY
OR TAKE THE FIFTH, THERE ARE
OTHER LEGAL HURDLES AND
CHALLENGES.
YOU'VE HAD SOME KEY RULINGS THAT
HAVE BENEFITED THE PRESIDENT
WHERE YOU'VE SEEN THE FEDERAL
JUDGES PUT A STOP TO SOME OF THE
NONSENSE, SAYING IT'S TOO WIDE A
SCOPE.
WE WANT TO SEE THE MEMOS.
CAN'T JUST ENGAGE IN A FISHING
EXPEDITION AND TRY TO REEL IN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS, AND ANYONE ELSE WHO
MIGHT HAVE COMMUNICATED WITH OR
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THIS.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
LEGAL HURDLES.
NOT TO MENTION HOW MANY PEOPLE
HE MIGHT HAVE COMING FORWARD
WITH TESTIMONY BETTER GOING TO
HAVE NO CREDIBILITY WHATSOEVER
IN TERMS OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT.
WHO IS GOING TO BE LEFT TO
TESTIFY WHO HASN'T MADE
INCONSISTENT STATEMENTS OR
RESIGN FROM THE FBI OR WRITTEN A
BOOK?
>> Juan: TWO PEOPLE LEFT OUT
OF THIS.
ONE, APPARENTLY JARED IS
DISPOSABLE.
IVANKA IS OFF LIMITS.
DON'T GO AFTER IVANKA.
MICHAEL COLLINS HAS YESTERDAY,
MICHAEL COHEN MAY BE COOPERATING
WITH MUELLER.
>> Greg: I WATCHED A LOT OF
THE COVERAGE WHEN I'M AT THE
GYM, NOT BY CHOICE.
THE REASON WHY I HATE IT SO MUCH
AND MOST OF AMERICA HATES IT,
IT'S LAWYERS INTERVIEWING
LAWYERS ABOUT WHAT A LAWYER
SAID.
WHAT ARE THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS
OF WHAT THEY SAID?
WE ARE NOT SURE.
LET'S GET A PANEL AND TALK ABOUT
IT.
THIS STORY IS SELF FUELED
HYSTERIA GENERATED BY THOSE IN
THE MEDIA WHO FEED OFF IT INSIDE
THEIR BUBBLE AND THEY DON'T CARE
THAT OUTSIDE THE BUBBLE AMERICA
REALLY DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN.
WE DON'T CARE.
THEY WAKE UP IN THE MORNING, TV
EXECUTIVE SAYING SHOULD WE DO
STORMY OR MUELLER?
SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
STORMING.
LET'S GET A PANEL AND TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
LET'S GET THE LEGAL PANEL TO
PARSE THE WORDS.
THEN WE GET THE NEXT PANEL FOR
THE POLITICAL RAMIFICATIONS.
WHILE THIS IS ALL GOING ON,
SOMEONE ELSE WILL START THE
PROCESS OVER AGAIN BY SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT MUELLER SO THAT
YOU CAN SWITCH FROM STORMY TO
MUELLER.
MEANWHILE TRUMP'S NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GO UP.
AMERICA GETS INCREDIBLY FED UP
AND BURNED OUT BY THIS AND I'M
TELLING YOU THERE'S GOING TO BE
A REBOUND TO THIS THAT'S GOING
TO HELP TRUMP BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
TIRED OF HEARING ABOUT LAWYERS
AND EXPERTS TALK ABOUT SUBPOENAS
AND SUMMARIZING FACTS THAT WE
DON'T GIVE A FLYING CRAP ABOUT.
>> Brian: THOSE JUDGES WHO
MADE THOSE COMMENTS, THEY CAME
ON SAID YOU DON'T WANT PAUL
MANAFORT.
YOU WANT TRUMP.
THE OTHER ONE SAYS YOU HAD AN
INDICTMENT.
ONE YOU PRODUCE THE EVIDENCE FOR
THE INDICTMENT?